[Music]
2022 was a strange year for breath of
the wild glitches with one particular
glitch that spawned a multitude of other
discoveries at a rate never seen before
and broke breath of the wild forever
with this being the final year before
the sequel let's take a look back and
see what happened in 2022
space exploration on January 22nd player
Legend of Link found that by having a
ridiculous amount of bone marrows and
combining two other glitches Death
Mountain Storage and moon jump you're
able to detonate link past breath of the
wild ceiling wind box and literally
escape to outer space players have
escaped Hyrule before in the past but it
was usually downwards or outwards never
this high up so this was a
never-before-seen angle of Hyrule
item transmutation
on February 25th 2022 users Kalin and
GTA Panda were theorizing through
Discord on how to use menu overloading
and selling items to their advantage and
found that the holding items in your
hands and value could be slapped onto
any other item which led to the
discovery of item transmutation turning
any small stack of materials into any
other more valuable item such as from
wood to Diamonds
but this was just the beginning as they
never knew that this would grandfather
in another glitch called inventory slot
transfer that would change breath of the
wild forever
hold prompt storage
while this prompt glitch is nothing new
and has been seen before outside of the
menu what wasn't found before was its
ability to hold items normally
impossible in normal gameplay on March
3rd it was found out by getting a
glitched prompt then pressing a and
pausing quickly on another item this
will force that item into your hands in
the Overworld such as the paraglider
chica slate korok seeds and even
undroppable items
this also allowed linked to cook said
items and even eat them which eating the
sugar slate doesn't sound too tasty
Goblin horse dealing
while the origin of this trick is
unknown it was found sometime in March
by having multiple horses shocked in an
area after you kick up a goblin off the
book hoblin when remounting will
sometimes get confused and pick up your
horse Instead This can include some
really strange steets such as your
favorite Mount giant horse or even the
lord of the mountain
[Music]
thanks
metal chest breaking
metal chests are completely invincible
and can't be normally destroyed like
with wooden chests but on April 26th
user drill karamari found that if you
bring a metal chest in the line of fire
of any of death Mountain's cannons these
powerful shots actually have a special
ability to destroy metal chests this led
to the hilarious discovery of dropping
armor from treasure chests in the
Overworld which then just floated in
space
scuba link first showcased by smajo Neko
on May 14th scuba link shows another
angle most players haven't seen deep
underwater
[Music]
while link was previously able to look
under the surface and sometimes dive the
camera always disconnected leaving deep
underwater exploration really up to your
imagination but this new method of
combining the Birdman minigame moon jump
and the gambling minigame then falling
into a body of water spawning a crowness
block then using revolia scale then
Shield surfing would then properly sync
both link and the camera downwards for a
full Deep dive experience and see many
unexplored areas for the first time
inventory slot transfer on June 17th
user ZX Robin showed off something
strange in a short Billy Billy video he
explained that he was able to duplicate
entire stacks of materials with a new
discovery with similar techniques to
item transmutation he used menu
overloading then holding and dropping
items before entering and exiting even
tide Island
this resulted in multiple stacks of
materials such as wood and giant ancient
cores and this was the first discovery
of creating an offset slot the base idea
for inventory slot transfer to carry
over specific items while reloading any
files this was huge this began some sort
of Renaissance in the breath of the wild
Community as it led to mass duplication
of any item you wanted including fairies
to become invincible
foreign starting a brand new game with
any equipment you wanted rediscovering
old assets Nintendo Never released
corrupting any meal you want using
direct inventory corruption to be edible
over and over and much much more
this was just the tip of the iceberg
blue Hyrule use your keynock found out
by using inventory slot transfer to a
new file but not picking up specific
items through the game can allow you to
have Glitch menu prompt such as an empty
meal slot letting you glitch a safe
prompt menu while the game is still
running in real time
by doing so right as you shoot Ganon in
the eye you could save the game after
you've beaten the game with Calamity
ganon's pillars around the castle a
cleared blue color the last canonical
state of Hyrule that's actually playable
before tears of the Kingdom
weapon modifier corruption the next
month on July 9th user keynock again
makes another game breaking Discovery
using inventory slot transfer and that
is weapon modifier corruption the final
frontier of equipment glitching in
breath of the wild with this glitch
players were able to force weapons to
have special overpowered modifiers and
heavily strengthen attack and defense of
equipment however you'd like today IST
and WMC have evolved so much that
advanced item manipulation has
completely broken the game highly
Advanced Techniques such as arrowless
offset prompt entanglement chain
material corruption invalid Arrow slot
invalid star slot k9c WMC K plus 1wmc K
plus 60wmc and piercing WMC streamline
this process more and more as time went
on to make corrupting equipment and
items more efficient any players willing
to dive down this complex Rabbit Hole
were rewarded with equipment materials
and meal setups players could only dream
of
Gerudo disarm finally we end with Gerudo
disarming found on September 25th 2022
user watch on found a way to disarm
enemies that are normally never
disarmable such as eager blade Masters
and even lionels
[Music]
by kiting set enemies to the front Gates
of kurudo town getting caught by the
guards at the gate on purpose will force
any nearby NPC to Stow their weapons
including enemies this changed their
behavior in strange ways because
Nintendo never designed these enemies to
function without their weapon which made
for some entertaining situations
[Music]
2022 was a major year for breath of the
Wild and the discovery of inventory slot
transfer and all of its sub glitches
changed the game forever we're now
waiting to see what the sequel tears of
the Kingdom will bring to the table
after a long six years in the oven if
you still enjoy a breath of the wild and
upcoming tears of the Kingdom content
make sure to stick around as we continue
to cover Zelda today and we'll bring in
the latest when it drops for everything
else keep it here on Gamespot
[Music]
[Music]
thank you